yeah I don't know
um
so it's come to my agenda that I made a
a grievous factual error
earlier uh there was this trivia
question where I asked what year did
Albert Meyer's first student graduate in
recall oh actually let me just go back
to that slide
it's important we get these details
right
um
so I asked you know Maya graduated from
PhD in Harvard in 1972
um he became faculty at MIT in 1969 I
asked when what year did Albert Meyer's
first PhD student graduate I thought it
was Nancy Lintz in 1972 but I was wrong
um he had a student in 1969
mccrite
um interestingly so Meyer was I I guess
at Harvard for his PhD and then became
faculty at MIT and he had a student at
Carnegie Mellon he graduated
in 1969 so uh what candy would you like
from the list
Hershey's okay great
all right and now that we've settled
that we can resume uh
oh
I'm back
okay here you can just pass it back I
think uh
all right
so now we can get back to the
hardness of mcsp
Eed
okay
great so I want to tell you guys a
little bit about uh the progress we've
made so far on proving mcsp's NP hard
I've told you a little bit about
hardness based on cryptographic
assumptions and the point that I wanted
to make with respect to that was that
these cryptographic tools
um could could be useful in proving NP
hardness for mcsp as we'll see later
kind of the most recent results are
making use of cryptographic ideas and
now I'm going to tell you about kind of
two different approaches to get that
work towards getting hardness for mcsp
itself and these are going to be results
that are not quite for mcsp but for
problems that are seemingly uh very
close to mcsp
and so the first approach that I want to
tell you about is approaching mcsp From
Below
and kind of the logic behind this is the
following intuition like so one reason
that people think it's hard to prevent
the hardness from mcsp is uh because we
don't have good circuit lower bounds so
this is something that I told you
earlier and it's it's kind of the logic
behind the limits for getting a
deterministic reduction from sat to mcsp
I actually if you really ask me I think
this intuition may not be correct
um and and we'll see a little bit about
that later some examples where it's not
clear that this intuition is really
capturing the difficulty of mcsp but uh
for now you could take that as some
intuition
um that that's something you could say
and in response to that you might have
the following idea okay we can't prove
hardness for mcsp because we don't have
good circuit lower bounds but what about
restricted circuit classes where we do
have good circuit lower bounds you know
maybe we can prove the NP hardness of
mcsp uh when you consider those circuit
classes so for example
um constant depth circuits maybe not all
of you are familiar with the lower
bounds literature but there are various
models of circuits for which we actually
do have uh lower bounds and this is the
approach that I kind of call approaching
mcsp From Below
where you consider the problem as I
mentioned earlier where the output is
does there exist a c circuit and we'll
see uh so now I'm going to mention
various circuit classes and what we know
about that problem
so the first problem that I want to talk
about is is dnf mcsp and so just as a
reminder dnfs are these objects where
you take uh ands on the inside and then
ores on the outside they're kind of
maybe the most basic model of
computation that's complete arguably uh
at least in the Andor setting
and you can think of these as kind of
like depth to circuits where uh you're
able to put two layers of gates on top
of each other
and one way
it's like the most basic model of and or
circuits that is like can complete in
the sense it can compute any function
there of course there are many
uh so if you like geometry better than
maybe logic one way you can view this is
you're Computing a function by like
covering the ones of that function by
Boolean sub cubes
and so this is like some sort of kind of
almost like a set cover problem and that
intuition will come up in empty hardness
of the stuff
so back in 1979 masic showed that the
dnf version of mcsp is NP hard his
original proof was like a direct
reduction from
uh three sad but uh or maybe not three
set but like
not it was really going through all the
details
and one thing that I want to emphasize
about this this was mentioned by Rahul
earlier is that you may view this result
as kind of counter-intuitive because on
the one hand dnf mcsp
eems like algorithmically an easier
problem than mcsp because like dnfs you
know
seemingly they're I mean simple objects
they're just uh ores of Boolean sub
cubes we can kind of understand them and
it might seem weird to you that okay if
we know that dnf mcsp isn't be hard then
of course the version of mcsp where you
consider General circuit should be
entered
but uh this intuition turns out like uh
not at least we don't know how to make
it formal and so it's somehow it seems
like this is also an easier problem to
show and be hardness for probably
because we can understand the no
instances of dnf mcsp better than we can
understand the no instances of regular
mcsb
okay
so back in 1979 basic showed that this
problem is empty heart and uh there's a
long line of work uh after that both
simplifying the proof and
proving better hardness and
approximation and this kind of
culminated by this theorem of code and
suket
that showed that dnfmcsp is NP hard to
approximate to a logarithmic factor
which turns out to be tight because this
is it turns out to be kind of basically
a set cover problem and for set cover
you have this greedy algorithm which
gets a login approximation fact
dfmcsp is basically completely
understood this is the problem that we
know is NP hard we know it's um
what is this the size of the DNA this is
the number of clothes oh good question
uh so you you can uh I think
traditionally they use like the number
of terms is it yeah they use like the
number of the number I guess it's the
number of ores here but if you uh
you can get hardness for both uh both
measures and pretty much any natural
measure you can get
yeah oh yeah so considering uh you know
it is counter-intuitive that's easier to
show any hardness for this given that it
does seem easier to solve but if we get
approximately up to a logarithmic Factor
whereas we're kind of looking at mcsp
gaps of like polynomial yeah I guess so
does that first point still kind of hold
that uh you know the harder the bigger
the circuit class you make the more
inapproximately you think it should be
yeah yeah I think that's true so like
dnf mcst Ian's question was uh related
to the inapproximate ability of this
problem so
um for dnf mcsp it's something that's
approximable to the logarithmic factor
and the algorithms are it's basically
based on the 3D set cover algorithm but
for mcsp if you believe in one-way
functions then this like really large
order versus chaos Gap uh is believed to
be intractable so that's an example of
where margin circuit class of makes it
more harder to approximately
oh yeah yeah and also though oh I should
have mentioned that when I said the
one-way functions thing but not only is
it this order versus cast problem hard
in the worst case but the the lower
bound based on one-way function shows
that's even hard to solve on average
because uh one of my functions are hard
to break on average
and I just want to mention uh I won't
talk about it in this this talk but the
this was extended to dnf with parity
gates at the bottom by uh shuichi Igor
and Rahul
and so okay deck two circuits we
completely understand them it's going to
be complete we know the approximation
algorithm we know in approximability
everything's perfect it's great all
right step three circuit mcspeed
oh Santa uh so CNF um circuit complexity
and dnf complexity they're basically the
same because if you take uh the not of a
function like if you can if you can
calculate the CNF complexity of an
arbitrary truth table you can calculate
the dnf complexity of arbitrary
tractable by just taking the knot so
like dnf complexity of f is equal to
this so the functions that require long
big significance
yeah I'm saying if you take a function f
and you look at it's not like not F the
function then the CNF complexity of f is
equal to the dnf complexity of not F
maybe there's another not no no that's
answering yeah
um and so like getting basically the
complexity of dnf mcsp is the same
good question uh is there another
question
because we don't understand average
guitar lessons
that's a uh average case hardness
um
yeah I guess over the uniform
distribution uh
well we think you could do this random
restrictions check
is that is
okay awesome thanks all right so step
two completely understood so step three
let's look at them CSP if you're not
familiar with what the three circuits
are here's like a little picture you got
like and Gates and then or Gates and
then and Gates Again or you could have
four gates at the bottom
at the top three levels of course and
ands you're allowed unlimited fan in and
so let me tell you what we know about uh
death tree from CSP
um so it's an MP and uh I think that's
it
I thought a little bit in fact it's even
opened whether this problem is
cryptographically hard uh we do know
that when you get to high enough depth I
think there's this paper by
um Eric and friends I think Mike sacks
on the paper uh hellerstein uh Tony's on
the paper there's a bunch of people on
the paper uh that show that once this
gets to a large enough constant I think
in the paper that you're marked maybe
around 10 that this problem is
cryptographically hard if you assume
that like factoring is hard or something
like that but at step three we don't
know that it's cryptographically hard we
don't know if it's NP hard we don't know
if there's an approximation algorithm uh
that's true we do have an average case
that yeah I should mention that we do
have an average case algorithm or
something uniform distribution natural
property you can check this random
restrictions technique Works
um but really we don't understand the
complexity of this and so what I was
saying earlier there's this intuition
that we can't prove hardness of mcsp
because we don't have a circuit lower
bounds I think this problem really
presents a difficulty for that intuition
because depth 3 circuits if you ask
people they would say that maybe they
understand it I mean I will say we don't
have like strongly exponential lower
bounds against step three circuits if
you know what that means great if you
don't know what that means don't worry
about it
um but uh yeah we really don't
understand this version of mcsp so this
is kind of a mystery
stuff I don't know there could even be
an approximation algorithm for this it
would be interesting
any questions
great okay so now I I've covered the
full gamut here we understand the depth
2 case we don't understand that free
case you might wonder if there's
anything more for me to say in this
approach from below and actually there
kind of is
it turns out if you don't consider
constant depth circuits but instead you
consider constant depth formulas uh we
understand the landscape a little bit
better so constant depth formulas
they're they're pretty similar to
constant depth circuits with the
exception that Gates can have fan out at
most one
and now you have constantly many levels
sorry
and so um a few years ago I was able to
show that
for any constant D it turns out that the
depth of D formula mcsp problem isn't
hard and this is based uh uses
randomized Turing reduction
um
and so one thing that I want to point
out about this I'm going to tell you a
little bit about how this is proved but
not too much
but this is another place where
Randomness shows up and in fact this is
kind of one of the most interesting
cases where randomnesses shows up
because uh the randomness used in this
reduction isn't used to get a uniformly
random function you might think you know
when you're using your Randomness you're
you're going to want to create some
really hard
uh function maybe so just pick one
uniformly at random it turns out in this
reduction you're not going to quite want
to do that there's something especially
that you want to do unfortunately I
can't tell you what that special thing
is but if you want if you're interested
you can ask me Lakers but this is like a
good demonstration of the power of
Randomness and how that's doing
something interesting
yeah oh and I should also mention this
is a quasi polynomial time reduction I
should have put that in in there yes
and it's not so common to have something
that requires training reductions it's
unclear I think
Eric you and Ru student work like uh
well anyway you guys were thinking a
little bit about whether you can make
this non-adaptive or something like that
uh we looked at that a little bit but we
didn't see it very far yeah so it's uh
seems at least so far we don't know how
to make this non-adaptive
but it's interesting that you know the
depth 3 circuit case we still don't
understand but at least for constant
depth formulas we do understand that
this problem is going to be hard
and so let me tell you a little bit
about how this is food and um in fact
what I want to tell you about how does
this group actually comes back to a
point I made earlier about kind of my
personal motivation there's a picture of
me as a kid and the dog
um
where by studying mcsp maybe we can get
our hands on some new interesting ideas
how to prove circuit lower balance and
to me this is like a good proof of
concept because we've got uh kind of new
lower bound technique that I'll tell you
a little bit about the next slide but
basically it's some technique that lets
you take
um if you have a deputy lower Bound for
a function you can come up with a new
function f Prime that will have a d plus
one more about and I'll tell you a
little bit about that on the next slide
but the way that you use that in this
reduction is by uh to get some inductive
approach where you start with the NP
hardness of dnf mcsp and then you whip
that to depth 3 formulas and you lift
that to debt four formulas and and you
repeat
and uh one one deficiency of this result
uh and uh where it could be improved is
it's hardness approximation isn't so
great it's like one uh one plus Epsilon
factor and that Epsilon Factor degrades
with d that's a potentially interesting
problem
any questions about uh this I'm gonna on
the next slide I'm gonna take a deep
tour to tell you a little about this
lower bound and how it maybe exemplifies
how looking at mcsp can lead us to new
circuits
okay great
so let me tell you about this lower
bound result
and it's related to this question like
what is the cost of parallel
organization if you're looking at uh
serial computation where you're allowed
to
um you take a lot of time take a lot of
depth in order to make your computation
versus where's and you want to do things
in parallel
and um
uh I want to say you know
he doesn't work I don't want to you know
go into them because this is just a
tangent in this talk but uh
one definition you can make in order to
formalize this question is you could say
let's look at L sub D of f which is like
the smallest size of any depth D formula
computer X this is like the circuit
complexity measure for depth defense
and then you can ask yourself well
if I have a function f and the worst
possible function f how large could this
quantity be how far apart could the
depth D complexity of f versus the D
plus one complexity of f b additively
yeah of course there's multiple ways you
can finalize let's see if you care about
multiplicative gaps we care about
something but one way you could do it is
by caring about the additive
and uh so what do we know about this
this question is so there's this
classical result based on the switching
gamma uh that shows that there does
exist a function for which you can get
this Gap kind of this uh mildly
exponential or weekly exponential I
think it was called earlier uh where it
turns out that it requires like two to
the N to the one over and D complexity
over here and get linear complexity at
depth D plus one so this is there's this
function it's based on these things
called the sips or functions
um where you have this really big gap
it's really easy to conceive at depth B
plus one but if you want to paralyze it
parallelize it and make it uh computable
Deputy you need to pay this exponential
exposure
and you might ask okay can we do better
over here and um
I think unfortunately it's been a big
open question of whether you can prove
explicit lower bounds uh bigger than two
to the N to the one over G this is like
one of the big questions in circuit
complexity
and uh since we since we don't have
lower bound techniques like that and uh
for a random function it's actually not
clear whether uh there should be a large
gap here or not I mean some intuition is
that okay let me not get into that but
using this lower bound technique that
really just fell out of mcsp result like
I really I wasn't trying to prove this
or anything it just after the mcsp
result it just turned out that you could
prove this you can actually like get an
exponential Improvement here instead of
this being two to the N to the one over
D this is going to be like 2 to the
point zero zero one uh n so like some
constant Factor here so you can get like
exponential Improvement and I think to
me this is like a good example of
help studying the mcsp problem you know
leads kind of naturally uh to examining
Google around technical that's a good
motivation then so this is like the
example I wanted to give at that
location
any questions
does this get TNA implications for
circular guns oh
um so I think the problem is that this
function is like very non-explicit it's
like some mix between a random function
and like parody images parity with
random restrictions which 1600 Watts
um
over here it's like some sort of mix
between like something like the central
function and a random function it's like
take it like it's almost like this
tree-like construction where you keep
taking products of the function with
random functions
yeah so far I don't I haven't found the
application for this since like
the next time
yeah so I think yeah you need like
non-deterministic circuits like lower
bound assumptions
yes
I don't know how to so here it's uh it
turns out for the specific function this
really is an additive
so that's something like over here you
have like linear versus exponential here
you have I mean both these terms are
going to look like this but there is but
you can prove that there's this additive
Gap I think it's interesting to study
the multiplicative case as well I don't
know how to do it but I mean some ideas
work some ideas don't work
I don't want to get uh too distracted by
this because the point of the talk is to
teach you guys about mcsp
e so I'm going to move on
and so the next model that I want to
talk about is is Formula mcsp where
instead of considering circuits we
consider formulas and so if you're not
familiar with formulas it's just
circuits where each gate can only have
fan out one so you can't like reuse the
output of the gate and it's it's pretty
related to parallel computation
and so
formula mcsp
um it turns out you can show that under
the exponential time hypothesis this
problem is not going to be in p
and this is the point at which I want to
return to this technique that I
mentioned earlier which is
sub-exponential reductions so have
exponential time deductions and tell you
a little bit about why they might be
useful and to show that formula mcsp and
maybe mcsp itself is not in P under
assumptions like in th
and so here is the logic behind this
if you look at the number of formulas of
size s
uh and you can you can calculate it
turns out the answer is going to be like
roughly like 2 to the S log n
uh and most of that is coming from like
labeling the leaves if you care about
that but whatever so what does that mean
it means that if you're going to do the
Brute Force algorithm which is the best
algorithm we know for this problem
that's going to take like two to the
order s log at the time
and you know that's bad if you're an
algorithms person but if you're if you
care about lower bounds then that might
be good
because that means that even when s is
linear when you're considering linear
size formulas The Brute Force algorithm
which is the best algorithm we know
doesn't even run in polynomial time and
so I want to stress here there's this
little n which is like the number of
variables to the function then there's
this capital N which is like the length
of the truth table so and that's the
input length so like even if you're
trying to decide whether a function has
linear sides formulas that's something
that at least the Brute Force algorithm
doesn't run in polynomial time
and so that suggests if you're like
interested in fine grain complexity
Maybe
you could possibly hope to show that
formula mcsp is not in P by considering
instances with linear size formulas and
those are those are things we know we
know formula lower balance even no
circuit lower bounds where um we have a
linear lower bound
and it turns out like you can actually
make this logic where oh wait did the
logic make sense before I go on yeah
you said I'm confused because you said
before the depth three formula is empty
heart yes
so without any eth you're right right so
this is this question is
um kind of uh an analogy to this the
fact that we know dnf mcsp is NP hard we
don't know whether for General circuits
essentially hard so similarly if you
restrict the depth we do know that
formula complexity is empty hard if
you've been addicted to a constant F but
if you don't have that restriction on
the depth it's on well yeah you no
wonder it doesn't imply that if it's MP
if it tend to be hard for a depth three
it doesn't imply that in general yeah
yeah
it's a yeah definitely is something
that's kind of weird for an intuitive
standpoint but I get the problem is like
you're the no instances of the constant
depth formula production might not be no
instances but for General formulas
so finally these statements are
incomparable as far as we know yeah
question
so uh yeah so there's this logic
basically the takeaway is that the Brute
Force algorithm runs in super polynomial
time even on these in small size
instances instances that we potentially
understand and because of that
um you could hope to prove using
fine-grained assumptions that form of
mcsp is not MP and uh in fact there's
this the reduction actually works from
this problem which sounds kind of nasty
but it's kind of nice to end by two end
bipartite permutation independent set it
was first considered by people in
parameterized complexity and they were
able to show that it requires like two
to the N log n time which you know you
look over here that's two to the N log n
that's two to the N log n you know
um and kind of I'll just give you one
idea from this because I don't want to
spend too much time on this but one of
the ideas is somehow the or function if
you look at its optimal circuits there's
many many optimal circuits for the ore
function because
um you can you have to order together
each one of the bits but you can do it
in any order you want so there's like n
factorial which equals 2 to the N log n
roughly optimal formulas that also looks
like this and so somehow you're able to
create some hardness where picking the
correct
um optimal formula for the or function
uh you're able to create some problem
based on that so
that kind of gives you some intuition
for this and I think this is like a good
example of like so proving hardness for
this problems we don't necessarily need
like really exotic
um lower bounds we could get away with
potentially easy lower bounds we just
need the right ones
in the right way uh and then the last
thing I want to mention about this is
that you also get a polynomial time
search decision reduction this question
of whether you can get a search decision
reduction for mcsp has been open for a
while but using ideas based on this you
can actually get a polynomial time such
recession reduction
um naively you'd get like a
sub-exponential one but you can actually
get a polynomial one but I don't want to
talk about the techniques for that too
much unless someone's interested
okay cool
and uh
well so one open question and I'll
mention this at the end is like this all
this logic applies to mcsp so can you
use this to show mcsps.np under eth you
know there's as far as I know there's no
barriers to doing this but I'll I'll
come back
when I talk about open questions
oh and look at that
so I think there's two main open
questions one is the um
depth of the NP hardness of depth three
circuit mcsp again we don't know
anything about this so I guess I really
should say or approximation algorithm or
cryptographic hardness anything about
the three circuit mcsp would be
interesting
um one thing that we do know is that
step three formula mcsp is NP hard and
uh formula complexity and circuit
complexity at depth 3 are actually
really close to each other there's
really not that much space to reuse
Gates if you think about it
um so they're they're only a factor of n
away from each other they seem really
close so the fact that we know that
depth 3 formulas mcsp is NP hard seems
like we should know depth three circuit
mcsp is not be hard but
and uh as I mentioned earlier the fact
that this question is open kind of
undermines this intuition that the
missing pieces is circuit lower bounds
and then the second open question I want
to mention in terms of approaching mcsp
below is can you show that mcsp is not
in P under eth uh there's seemingly no
barrier to showing this
um it seems like it just needs like one
new idea maybe not even an interesting
idea like uh
[Music]
um just seems to require one new idea I
think
I think so that concludes uh what I'm
talking about in the approach From Below
uh now I'm going to talk about a
different way to get towards
um hardness of mcsp which is approaching
things oh sorry Alex
is there any interesting
circuit class
where we know that mcsp for that circuit
class is not in the heart
okay yeah that's a good question
um
what do you mean by we know it's not
empty heart
I guess I mean I guess or okay sure that
that might be difficult to say but I
guess maybe where there's like an
entrepreneurial algorithm that makes it
unlikely
I think the tricky part about this is
like
um
kind of almost any interesting circuit
class at least when you get past the
constant depth side it's going to be
able to implement cryptography and once
you can Implement cryptography then
you're not gonna be able to get an
algorithm for it because plus like a
similar logic to earlier in the slides
like if you can um
solve the problem you can break one-way
functions computable in that model
one example is like between the minimum
depth of a decision tree
we've done a Time polynomial
so let me just repeat the question or
repeat the answer in case anybody didn't
hear it but Ryan pointed out that if you
consider the model the decision tree
model which is like and the like the
version of minimum circuit size problem
for decision trees you can actually
solve that for polynomial time so you
can find the size of the smallest uh
smallest depth of any decision Tree in
polynomial time
or maybe a less interesting example but
one that's
relevant if you look at circuits with
qbf
Oracle Gates
so that's provably not hard even for p
under ac0 term reductions
so Eric is saying if you consider these
circuit classes where you allow qbf
workout
let me talk about just a pressure above
which takes a different tack at trying
to get towards mcsp
e and uh so what do we mean by
approaching mcsd From Below above it
means showing problems that are we know
are harder than mcspu or in other words
general relationship generalization so
mcspr and be hard and so that sounds a
little bit abstract so let me give you
some examples
so the original definition of mcsp looks
like this
um but you could imagine instead of
putting a total function here you could
allow partial functions or instead of
requiring a function with one bit of
output you could allow multiple bits of
output and then ask okay can we show
that this problem is NP hard
and uh proving NP hardness for these
problems for uh these generalizations
from CSP are logically necessary for
showing mcsp's NP hard so it's very
natural to try and attack them
okay so let me go to our first example
which is a conditional mcsp
so this is some conditional version of
mcsb
um and its input is mostly the same it
still takes in the truth table Boolean
function it still takes in a size
threshold but now it's going to take in
a second truth table it's going to be a
truth table of some Oracle uh Boolean
function uh oh I'll call O from M bits
to zero one bits and now the question is
going to be does there exist a circuit
with o Oracle Gates and let's say s wire
is Computing f
so if you think about this in like some
sort of like conditional version of mcsp
where now there's going to be multiple
truth tables and you ask you know
relative to some other truth table is is
this thing hard
um and it I think what's interesting
about this result and the reason why I
put it up is it has this kind of
dichotomy where on the one hand if you
consider deterministic reductions
getting and showing this problem is MP
hard under deterministic Productions
requires separating X from zpp which we
don't know how to do
but on the other hand you can actually
show that under randomized reductions
this problem is NP hard in fact this
this proof is actually not not too hard
to show
so um it's this it gives a good example
where Randomness is like provably useful
uh in terms of proving the NP hardness
of mcsp
foreign I should say there are some
great extensions of this work to the
komogoro setting I don't want to as I
said at the beginning of the talk I
didn't really want to talk too much
about the Commodore setting to limit the
amount of definitions I have to give but
these results are really interesting in
that
they they give examples of NP complete
problems whose average case complexity
characterizes one-way functions but
maybe we'll hear about them more
tomorrow
and the last thing I want to mention is
that there's this result by hirohara at
this year CCC which gives uh
at least much stronger in
approximability for this problem so like
one kind of theme in meta complexity is
that of the hardness results that we're
able to prove
we're not able to get very good
approximation uh hardness of
approximation for these problems so
here are Horrors it's all result is one
of the first that gets like good
hardness of approximation I think it's
like
uh n to the one over log log n but uh
it's still much better than before where
we only had like logarithmic Factor
hardness
okay so that's what I wanted to say
about uh conditional MCS oh yes Market
ing
about
Productions so it's like giving an extra
strength due to the benefits for great
for the circuit succinctly yeah is you
know if you made that empty you would
get everything you'd get everything so
right now it has to be I think you can
get like any polynomial relationship
with n that you want
um with sufficient padding and stuff
like that
yeah you can get that I don't I don't
know how to do lower than that
but it's a good question I mean
in some sense you can interpret your
Horror's result uh most recent result of
sewing you can show if you set things up
correctly you can set n equal to like
log n uh which is crazy log little web
uh sorry no log Capital One if you
interpret it in the right way but
okay cool
um let's see I think I'm gonna I think
I'm gonna skip this proof idea it's not
very hard
um but it turns out that
and some of the ideas show up a little
bit in later on but I think I may skip
this one
okay so the next variant of fcsb that I
wanted to talk about is is the
multi-output variant of mcsp now uh
instead of having talking about a single
output function you talk about a
function with multiple outputs instead
of just one bit you get potentially M
bits and your output is now going to be
does there exist a multi-output function
of size at most s Computing f
and it turns out here
um together with ior who's here and
Bruno who uh is not here right now
um be able to show that this problem is
and be hard under randomized training
reductions and again it's an example of
where you can use randomized reductions
somehow the key idea is related to
almost similar like symmetry of
information which I didn't think we
would see today but we ended up seeing
uh which was nice but uh you can there's
this chain rule in
information Theory where you have if you
look at the entropy of two joint random
variables it's related to the
conditional entropy
and kind of our reduction works like
this where it's it starts with this
conditional version and it's able to
show that the multi-output version is
hard
but I also don't want to concentrate too
much on this result
but one one thing that I do want to
emphasize is that this does require a
lot of output so M here is polynomally
related to capital N so the question of
of squishing that down to like less and
less outputs isn't interesting is
another way to approach mcsp and is
something we don't really understand
all right I think the number of output
is like exponentially in the number of
inputs yeah number of outputs is
exponential in the number of inputs
all right any other questions
the size threshold is going to be like I
guess polynomial the length of the uh
thing like
it's a the reduction is also based on
set cover like the like the previous one
all right and that brings us to
second trivia break all right
there are lots of great prizes left left
here
um so the first trivia is about lenoid
Levin
and uh the question is
Levin's discovery of the theory of NP
completeness was in part motivated by a
dispute with his blank who was skeptical
on the usefulness of theory
sure definitely something uh so answer a
advisor
answer B rooming
answer C
so who thinks the answer is a
all right Craig um my reasoning is that
yeah you never told us we weren't
allowed to answer for all of the options
oh so I figured that to the optimal
strategy all right who thinks the answer
is B
itch I don't think it was the mother
anyone thinks the answer is C mother
let me say
I don't know
it's the most interesting answer
based the most information so the answer
is be roommate uh so the the precise
quote here was this is coming from
Robin's blood later I got into dispute
with Yuri Albertson my roommate in our
undergraduate dorm he's skeptical in the
usefulness of theory and gave me give
commentatorial optimize optimization
methods as examples of real issues I
argue these algorithms are just
heuristics and some combinatorial
problems like tiling are very tiling was
one of the first problems he showed was
empty complete are very likely solvable
he dismissed tiling as a toy problem but
I said one can try to show this for
other problems by reducing tiling to
them I proceeded developing several such
reductions komogorov his advisor found
this very interesting and wanted me to
publish it I however viewed these
problems as of Interest
all right so what what candy what would
you want for your prize Reese's please
releases
right I've resorted to passing this back
uh as a safer method
all right Reese's are all both Reeses
are off the table I got two of them
because I thought they would be popular
so in this next trivia segment our last
questions and you will need to answer
which problem is this referring to
the other Rojo does not get to answer or
maybe he does but
um so the first question is who played
baseball on a University team is it a
raw
foreign
who thinks the answer is a Rahul oh okay
okay I guess when I call I guess all of
you should raise your hands really like
but when I call on you you have to
specify which which role uh okay okay
what do you think Tom uh him okay
because MIT doesn't have a team
anybody want to take the counter side of
that
you because Rutgers has a team oh really
because so I gotta say this one's a bit
of a trick question
I believe was the captain of his
intramural baseball team in graduate
school right
yes softball softball oh I see okay okay
and you guys were not the opposite of
undefeated right
um
[Laughter]
so uh Paul what surprise would you like
you like you don't have none mint
kitkats I do not have non-min can cat a
lot a big Starburst Starburst okay
there you go
enjoy your friends
[Music]
I thought they were going to be really
popular I thought they would rival the
Reese's Pieces
um okay and then the second and last
question is who said mcsp is more
fundamental than sad was it a Raul
at this point both of you
all right what do you think
no I think it's me all right
is this guy it's um oh Marco what do you
think I think it's also other real life
why did everybody wins everybody wins so
yeah okay I'm gonna give out two pieces
of candy for this one uh so what would
you like Marco uh
you would like them in KitKat
and what would you like oh okay
well those those ones
so this this quote uh I guess you got an
argument with lanceport now or something
like this about whether mcsp is more
fundamental than that I think Lance's
opinion was it was ridiculous or
something like that
um and then so I was visiting the other
Rahul he was telling you about this and
I was like can I can I quote you on this
and he was very generously said yes and
then for many years I started all my
Talks by saying mcsp is more fundamental
than sat quote Rahul
and then then I had to turn the slide
and I'd be like uh Rahul snap phenomenon
question mark so this is technically as
I said by another raffle I don't uh yeah
by me as well
I'm still being convinced but uh yeah
okay so that's the end of our trivia
segment I guess we do have
extra candy so if anybody asks any
really good questions you may be and get
some fun dip and Milk Duds
okay cool
cool so now we get to our uh
big big problem partial function mcsp
this is where some really substantial
progress that's been made uh very
recently so what is partial function
mcsp
it's where your input is going to be the
truth table of now a partial functions
some function from zero one n to zero
one star and I want to stress here
you're still given this full truth table
it's not like you don't have to describe
the things in the stars or something and
you can make it exponentially more
succinct you still have to specify this
whole 2D length truth table it's just
that there are some inputs where you
kind of like don't care about the output
if you like you can think of these stars
as question marks instead yeah does
there exist a circuit of size at most s
Computing F on all the zero one values
any questions about the definition of
this
and I want to stress that this at least
historically has been a very important
intermediate problem so for the dnf mcsp
uh NP hardness results uh the modern
version of that proof actually starts by
showing this problem is empty heart and
then reducing this problem to the total
function version as well as the result
that formula mcsp is not in P under eth
that also goes through the partial
function version so historically this
has been an intermediate problem and
kind of an important stepping stone to
hardness events it doesn't mean NP
intermediate when you're saying oh yeah
yeah I mean like uh yeah in English
exactly
um yeah I guess this is ambiguous so I
under deterministic reductions we knew
that this problem was was not in P under
eth kind of using the same techniques as
the formula uh results but and and that
was using like sub exponential
reductions but I think what's been
really amazing is in in the past year
shuichi has shown that this is NP hard
under randomized reductions and I I just
want to say I really did not
really did not think that this was this
was going to be possible anytime soon
it's really an amazing result I'm like
really happy I've seen it and I think
you guys should definitely I'm going to
cover a little bit about it but like you
guys should definitely go and read this
paper because it's really amazing
um and one thing that I want to
emphasize about this hardness result
versus almost all the other previous
hard test results that we've seen is
that uh a lot of the previous hardness
results were kind of model dependent in
that like okay they show constant depth
formulas it's empty hard
um but that's it like they showed fat
models NPR certain versions of mcsp
might be hard this argument is very
general it works for like mcsp star and
a whole slew of related problems and
this really seems like the right way to
attack the problem and uh the way that
this is proved I'm going to tell you a
little bit about it but not too much is
again it's going to use randomized
reductions but I think the key
true innovation in this proof are the
cryptographic tool settings uh the proof
really has these cryptographic ideas in
it and it seems like this is going to be
an important part in showing mcsp itself
is going to be hard and so let me tell
you a little bit about those
cryptographic tools
daily cryptographic tools one of them
is secret sharing how how many people in
this audience actually with secretary
yeah I'm going to tell you what secret
sharing is but it's this beautiful
um in in this case we're interested in
information theoretic notion which I
think came first it's this beautiful
idea from cryptography about how if you
want to have a secret and you want to
split it among certain parties
um what what ways you can do that so
that all the parties have to get
together to reconstruct your secret I'll
explain in more detail later but this is
a very interesting cryptographic tool
and the other thing is an information
theoretic encryption screen against
small programs and it turns out like
this sounds very complicated but if
you're a cryptographer for example like
a gold Reich 11 Works to do this
so these are two cryptographic ideas
which are kind of like the main tools
used to prove or two of the main tools I
would say
um
used to prove its results
so let me tell you uh a little bit about
that but before that I want to make a
comment at the beginning of this talk I
told you about this dream where it's
like
P naught equals NP implies mcsp is hard
the worst case applies average case blah
blah blah implies one-way function like
this
and this is something that uh thanks to
Lou and pask uh we've known about for a
few years and I think people have been
thinking about and people were thinking
we can use mcsp and NP hardness mcsp to
answer questions in cryptography and I
think what's really interesting about
this is that actually the two areas
might be even more intertwined than we
thought in the NP hardness of mcsp
actually might be using cryptographic
techniques and uh maybe like this idea
NP hardness and the existence of one-way
functions or at least I think in
cryptography
you know maybe uh they're more connected
than we thought so I think I think
that's really interesting
Okay so
in the remaining few minutes I'm going
to try and tell you a little bit about
how this reduction works
and the first thing I'm going to tell
you about is the problem that your heart
is reducing from it's not so important
that you understand this problem I just
want to give you some flavor of it but
it's uh
given some monotone formula fee you want
to estimate the minimum number of ones
of any satisfying assignment to feed and
so this problem was proved and be hard
and then there's some work that shows
that it's hard to approximate but for
now all you need to know is that this
problem is and be honest and it sounds
like an FBI problem it seems believable
that it would be fun
and the second key ingredient that I
want to focus on that I mentioned
already is uh secret sharing for
monotone formula fee so this is kind of
a classic result in secret sharing
a secret sharing in this sense means
that there there's some algorithm share
and there's some algorithm reconstruct
that are randomized
and when you run share on a formula fee
and a bit B
it's going to Output these strings S1 up
to SN which are called secret shares and
these things are made meant so that you
can hand them to parties uh one up to n
and each one of them their secret shares
and the point is that
if you look at any adversary that gets
to see all the set of shares in a set t
you the way that this uh algorithm is
set up is if fee evaluates to one on
those people so you can interpret the
set as an assignment where you have like
zero going to people who uh items that
are r t and one going to things that are
r t if V values to one on this indicator
you're able to reconstruct what the bit
B is otherwise if you don't have access
to a set of shares for which the formula
to be is satisfiable then B is
information theoretically here
so again if you don't fully understand
this it's I wouldn't worry about it so
much just some tool from cryptography uh
that hopefully I've reminded you of if
not don't worry about it too much
are there any like pressing questions
about this stuff
oh you have questions yeah well I was
just wondering if it matters at all what
secret sharing uh Escape me is or I
think in the proof it doesn't matter
besides like you need some like
efficiency parameters and stuff like
that
there is a very simple scheme to do this
now yeah
and so if you combine these two things
together it says that like if you're
given some formula fee there's some way
of constructing if picking a random bit
B and generating shares such that
determining the minimum number of shares
needed to reconstruct B is hard because
here you can reconstruct B if you if B
is a set if something is a satisfying
assignment uh satisfying it uh and here
it's saying like the minimum number of
ones in any satisfying assignments
I'm going to tell you how the reduction
works and uh I probably will skip
correctness or something traditions
so I'm going to say we have as a second
tool some sort of encryption scheme it
doesn't really matter for the intuition
I'm going to give what this encryption
scheme does it's just something that has
a secret key
um and given a message and it puts out
the ciphertext given a and it has a
decryption algorithm as well
and what the reduction look like is as
follows
oh I should say I'm not going to tell
you the actual reduction I'm going to
tell you a really really
terrible reduction in fact it's going to
be so inefficient it's going to be worse
than the Brute Force algorithm but I'm
gonna it's gonna involve some of the
ideas
of the original proof and that's what I
wanted to convey uh here and so it's
given fee what are you going to do
you're going to pick some random secret
Keys
um there might be a security parameter
associated with don't worry about that
now for interposition for intuition and
you're going to construct a partial
truth table as follows you're going to
first set all the
um
values in the truth table to star or
question mark and then after that you're
going to fill in the non-stars by
repeating the process
um
uh following process many times you'll
pick a b uniformly at random then you'll
let um S1 up to SN for your secret
shares
then you're gonna let X be your uh an
encryption of the first secret share
with the first secret key and then up to
the concatenation of that with the last
secret share according to the last
Secret
and I want to point out that because
you're going to repeat this for like all
two possible choices of Randomness here
because the share secret sharing
algorithm has Randomness encryption has
Randomness the D has Randomness and
that's why this is going to have a
normal size
um but let's not worry about efficiency
for now you could construct this group
table and this is
um
you know giving you some ideas uh uh
some of the main ideas in this reduction
uh and okay maybe I'll tell you a little
bit about why you might have uh
correctness in the yes case in the yes
case if there's a small set of
authorized shares
or sorry if um fee has a small
satisfying assignment which means that
there's like a small set of shares you
need to reconstruct you can create a
small circuit by just memorizing the
secret Keys corresponding to that uh
small set of authorized shares and then
when you're given an input of the form X
you'll decrypt it to find this
corresponding secret shares and then
reconstruct to find the bit B
so the idea here is if there's a small
number of shares somehow you need to
only know a few uh of the secret Keys
here
and so this this is set up so that the
circuit has size like uh maybe something
like the size of the authorized set
times Lambda
and then in the no case
um
where there's no small set of authorized
shares
roughly the intuition will work like
this any circuit that's able to compute
B must look at many secret shares by the
security of the secret sharing scheme
and uh then by the security of the
encryption scheme it needs to know that
many secret keys and so the circuit
needs to have like many secret keys
hardwired and so they're supposed to be
large so uh you know if you followed
that great if not that's okay I think we
should yeah hopefully my goal here is
just to get you interested in this paper
and uh hopefully take a look at it
where's the personalists come into the I
mean
how much of it are you filling yeah so
you'll only end up filling out I think
like a polynomial small fraction
polynomial a small fraction so the point
is that these encryptions
um you're not everything is going to be
a valid encryption
um not everything is going to be a valid
secret share so because of that there's
going to be some inputs here x which are
not corresponding to encryptions and not
corresponding to secret shares and
that's where these question marks are
coming from
um other questions also this is like the
last item
s to cover
if you have questions so if one of these
like this worst trivial signature and
schemes from earlier Works would you
still have got through some differences
speak just with more stars or
so I believe okay from when I talked to
shuichi and he was explaining to me the
secret sharing scheme that he's using is
like I'm imagining it probably is one of
your what you're talking about with the
trivial Secrets China scheme where it's
like if there's an or gate on top you
hand the bit to both parties then if
there's an and gate you do like some
parody thing
oh it's not to use like a more advanced
one but no city is the same as
I believe so at least that's when when I
was meeting with them this is the most
efficient uh stimulus known from
formulas
you just figure for 30 seconds
yeah sure
why if you use encryption encryption
yeah so the encryption and decryption
that's the way so like you're bound on
the circuit size here uh uh here is
somehow related to the fact that
um unless you decrypt enough of these
guys you're not going to know the bit B
and in order to decrypt enough of those
guys you have to pay for their secret
keys
so the encryption and decryption thing
is the goal of that is to make any
circuit that's successfully able to
compute this function have to know a
certain amount of secret Keys basically
a seat number of secret Keys
proportional to the number of ones
needed to evaluate sorry the minimum
monotone satisfies
that makes sense so if it's like if
there's the the shares are out there and
it's plain texts and yeah Fisheries were
out there in plain text then you could
imagine us there's oh there's a circuit
for getting B which just runs the
Reconstruction algorithm on all the
shares and that's going to be a small
circuit but if you have if you encrypt
the shares then you have to in order to
decrypt enough of the uh secret shares
in order to get the bit B you have to
pay for each one of the secret keys if
uh
yeah yeah so you'll have to pay for like
however many uh shares you want to get
times Lambda of course I'm giving you
some intuition that like maybe there's
something smarter than you can do that
just memorize the secret key but if you
set things up right you get a bound like
that
any other questions about this
so then let me leave you with this open
question NP hardness for mcsp
e uh can you extend your heart from
partial mcsp to mcsp
e yeah we have partial total derive
actions in other contexts
um there is this Oracle independent
reductions barrier it seems like his
result is not is not
uh or sorry is Oracle independent
so you maybe have to get around that but
I don't I don't know like it seems
really close to settling the mcsp
problem
and uh if you have any questions feel
free to ask me
yeah thank you so much for this question
of like when is it that the essence
which is a small search okay
it's not the case for all the reductions
from above very good
so you're not just as much as yourself
okay
so you're asking the essence since these
are small circuits and the no instances
have large Commodore complexity that's
going to be true for and you're asking
for the approach from above right yeah
I'm just wondering if the statistics
okay I'd have to think about it but my
initial answer is like I think all of
them might be circuit complexity
foreign
here are my shares and then you did oh
okay so that you're going to repeat this
process with many different bits of
Randomness for the secret share and
you're gonna repeat this process with
many bits of basically go over all
possible Randomness for the encryption
so that your your remaining star values
are going to correspond to things that
aren't encryptions and like aren't uh
yeah it was very nice Parts in the end
because you did every possible secret
care secret character share of stuff so
you're talking about the sparsity of the
non-stars right okay yeah yeah so it
ends up being like a one over polynomial
and when do you stop you just do all
possible
specify this reduction is inefficient
actually I mean a good exercise I think
or a fun exercise is to try and think
about like how you would possible like
what ideas would you need to make this
efficient I mean and I think that's
what's really amazing about community's
results Is Not only was he able to put
together secret sharing and encryption
in this way the techniques you need to
get an inefficient reduction in fact uh
this shows that some other
problems related to meta complexities
and be hard but who's able to go from
that and then take this and make this
efficient enough to work in the mcsp
partial mcsp setting
but I don't spoil
uh yeah do you have any Intuition or
like when is it possible to Total
reduction for various kind of benefits
yeah so
as far as I know there are only two
examples one is for dnf mcsp and the
other is for formula and CSP for dnf
mcsp you really need to understand how
dnfs work that seems like very specific
you need a specific lower bound there
for formula mcsp there's this one trick
this that book Fury everyone's invented
called formula Leaf weighting and based
on that you can do something but even
that's like an exponential
um search exponentials
size for every one
yes and yeah and then the exponential at
precise exponential matters because you
want to be less than this like two to
the end log n
here
[Music]
I would say the partial total reductions
are quite ad hoc but uh yeah who knows I
I will say a comment on this
so for the formula mcsp result
originally I showed that partial mcsp is
not in the under eth and I was like I
don't think that you can do a partial to
Total reduction formulas then it ended
up being you could do a partial total
reduction for one of those so I'm
cautious I also think you can't do a
partial production for circuits but I
thought that about formulas and it
turned out some could do performance
so
any other questions oh yes yes when you
strip aside the specifics of the
Machinery what's the what's the big
difference between the CR approach and
all the results that you had in terms of
say how it uses Randomness is it like
you just blatantly use the randomness
whereas he uses a secret keys or is
there is it deeper than does it in a
personalized way so if you're familiar
with the Oracle mcsp result
um I I know I skipped over the proof but
you could if you glance at this in the
right way the encryptions here or Oracle
access is there and the seek and the
secret sharing there is
um kind of like a trivial secret sharing
scheme uh where it's just like you
secret share something between three
parties where any one of them can
recover the secret share so you just
tell each one of them the answers it's
like a really simple super generic
scheme so there is some sense in which
you can interpret that result in this
contact or this is a generalization of
that
um so then what is it about the
generalization that gets these that you
know goes from eth all the way to the
hardness is it is less randomness
oh okay so that Oracle mcspeed result
that's not empty uh that's not eth
that's NP hardness oh okay and let me
tell you like the generalization of that
the idea to use secret sharing and
encryption that's like a huge jump like
that already like that but yeah how you
make this inefficient to efficient
requires new ideas to work
yeah yeah and then let's say you know
yeah it's a big part of it
maybe I think and now but uh one thing
that should mentioned to me when I was
talking to him is that he actually
wasn't aiming to hear what problem was
empty heart I don't know I mean like
I don't know if he thought that it would
be possible to show his empty part or or
what what his thought process was but
what he told me is he was aiming for Mid
LT and then he like followed the rabbit
hole and he got to this so